- So who were some of your
LGBTQ role models growing up?
- I think Billie Jean
King, Martina Navratilova.
- [Kelly] Sports, yeah.
- Yeah, because their genius
and their exceptional
talent, it's unassailable.
They are absolutely at
the top of their game.
So powerful.
And it cannot be questioned.
Like Brittney Griner,
her excellence cannot
be questioned, you know?
We need these incredible athletes here.
We need them in our country, in our world,
and we need to idolize them
because it's like they're,
I know they're unmatched, you know?
So that's what I love.
- It's awesome too, like with athletes,
I'm always like, gees,
I guess that's what we're capable of.
Like, I'm never gonna know
'cause I'm not working that hard.
But you watch them and
you're like, God, that's
the human body is capable
of amazing things.
- [Margaret] It's incredible.
- Yeah.
- I mean, I can't even walk
a couple of blocks, so.
- Without like a deep breath.
- Without like hats,
Deet, covered in Deet.
No, I'm really like
impressed by the courage,
especially in such any sort
of like male dominated field
like sports.
- Yeah.
- You know, when women can excel.
- It's cool for little
girls to see that too, yeah.
- Yeah.
It's powerful.
- [Kelly] It's good to see that, yeah.
- I love it.